hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
msnbc is still completely insane don't
call the raspberry the stuff that rudy
did
it seems like they're kind of like
obviously guilty dead to rights is what
it looks like and that's not a legal
opinion
but i want to say we i feel like we
actually need to go farther back in time
um we are sitting here in new york city
and rudy giuliani was of course the
long-time mayor of new york there this
is a real like arc of the moral universe
moment here
because uh this is a man before he was
america's mayor he was the tough on
crime mayor he made his career um
actually
as a prosecutor in the most prestigious
office in the land and then went on to
become the mayor in which he delighted
in putting away petty criminals uh
mostly young black and brown people uh
at rikers island and uh sending people
off um
and for far smaller crimes than he seems
to be under investigation for so i think
the fact now that he has been kind of
unmasked unfortunately as someone who
has evolved into being
closer to a fascist than america's mayor
is extremely disturbing it should
provoke some soul-searching
among all of us who
have seen his career in other stages
how did new york city produce this how
did america produce this figure i don't
know but i will tell you that uh he is
it's just it's a remarkable human story
it's actually not just a political story
at this point um it's going to change
his obituary it's going to be on his
tombstone and it's a sad sad uh kind of
political end to a long and storied
career they took his law license away
and and having been a squeegee man
myself for a period of time i felt happy
that day because i was like i remember
back in those days he was mean to the
squeegee man it was like really it was
bad he was a budding fascist even then